commercial DNA tests have been a huge
trend lately they were some of the most
popular holiday gifts last year which
makes sense there's so much excitement
in learning more about yourself some
tests can shed light on health risks you
might have but the main ones tell you
the composition of your ancestry
it looks like DNA's helpful too crazy
origin but for me I already know my
origins
that's my dad he's very proud of me
because I'm doing great things in life
chicken number one kills chicken number
two in this competition I was born in
Eritrea Eritrea is located in Northeast
Africa his family kept a detailed record
of their ancestors so that they would
never forget where they came from up to
the sixth generation I know even where
they are buried and where they used to
have their farmland some people cross
from Asia and people stayed in Africa
they live together during war during
peace and they inter married I wonder
though could this be more accurate than
a DNA test I'm not that familiar with
DNA but it because the origins of humans
your DNA will classify you as heavily
African in partly Asian let's find out I
ordered two DNA tests the helix test
from National Geographic and 23andme
unboxing the tests was kind of exciting
they were neat and they had simple
instructions generating enough spit was
a challenge and I'm so sorry you have to
watch this a few weeks later
let's start with national Geographics
helix test the results classify me as
East African it says that 62% of my DNA
can be traced to the continent of Africa
and 36 percent can be traced to Asia
this is in line with what my dad
predicted but I'm a little skeptical
that my Asian ancestry is so prominent
helix also noted that two percent of my
DNA could be traced back to Europe
specifically the West Mediterranean this
reason does include Italy which did
occupy parts of the Horn of Africa in
the 1800s which could explain part of
that two percent one thing that struck
me about the helix test was this a
description of East Africa it tells me
that my ancestry is associated with the
birthplace of humankind as well as the
departure point for human migration Out
of Africa this made me feel like a key
part of human history if only this
ancestral journey didn't lead to a man
who spends hours making spongebob days
now let's look at the 23andme test 94.6%
Eritrean Ethiopian 2.4% Sudanese and
0.3% broadly South Asia this test puts
much more emphasis on my African
ancestry and a lot less on my Asian
ancestry there was also no mention of
any European ancestry this makes a lot
more sense to me but I wonder how to
separate DNA tests can produce such
different results so we take your DNA
and we compare you to reference datasets
from around the world Robin Smith is 23
Angie's group product manager to find
out your ancestry DNA tests compare your
DNA with DNA from people around the
world and depending on the company these
reference datasets can vary seen your
result here it looks like Ethiopian and
Eritrean so that's that's they a group
for which you know maybe a few years ago
we wouldn't have had much of a data set
but now because of our size you know
we've got a lot of data from that region
so we're able to provide very good
granularity there some regions of the
world aren't as represented as others in
these referee
two datasets leading to some
disappointingly vague results for some
customers thankfully my DNA tests were
pretty accurate but at the end of the
day they just confirmed what my dad
already knew